Mein heutiger Vortrag wird, wie Sie bereits
sagten,
über Digitalität, Virtualität und Information sein,
und was ich tun werde, ist,
diese Konzepte zu klären,
insbesondere
die Konzeption von Digitalität, die sozusagen ein
ziemlich neues Wort oder
Konzept ist, aber auch Virtualität,
weil i  denke, dass
es eine tiefe Verwirrung darüber gibt, was
virtuelle Realität eigentlich
ist im Vergleich zu bloßer Simulation, das
war eine Frage, die gestern
nach einem Vortrag aufkam, und ich werde
dieses Thema in diesem folgenden
Vortrag wirklich diskutieren,
also ist die Gliederung meines Vortrags zuerst i
Ich möchte etwas über den Gegensatz sagen, den Unterschied zwischen Digitalisierung und Digitalität. Ich denke, das
ist ein sehr entscheidender Unterschied.
Dann werde ich zwischen
Simulation und Virtualität unterscheiden, was in
etwa der Unterscheidung zwischen
Digitalisierung und Digitalität entspricht.
Dann werde ich diskutieren, was Baby Chalmers
hat  Kürzlich
als virtueller Realismus und virtueller
Digitalismus bezeichnet,
denke ich, dass das wirklich hilfreich ist, aber es ist
nicht
ganz was  Ich denke, das ist wahr,
dann werde ich die Rolle des
Internets
als das, was ich ein Paradigma der Digitalität nenne, diskutieren.
Ich denke, es ist ein wirklich interessantes
Phänomen, es ist nicht nur ein Medium, es ist
etwas
viel wichtigeres als ein bloßes Medium,
das Internet,
und schließlich möchte ich es  entwickle und
stelle auch zur diskussion
drei kategorien von digitalität, wie ich sie
verstehe
erstens das, was ich ubiquitären präsentismus nenne
zweitens transsubjektivität und schließlich das,
was ich interobjektivität nenne
ich denke, dass diese
drei
kategorien das phänomen der
digitalität
in angemessener gegensätzlicher weise erfassen  bloße
digitalisierung, also denke ich, dass wir neue
konzepte brauchen, um
das neue phänomen der digitalität
im gegensatz zum rein technischen
phänomen der
digitalisierung zu verstehen, also kommen wir zum ersten
punkt
digitalisierung versus digitalität,
also wie können wir
streng genommen philosophisch über digitalisierung sprechen, meine ich  als
technologisches phänomen können
wir natürlich von diesem äh phänomen
p sprechen  philosophisch, aber
streng philosophisch gesehen
denke ich, dass wir zunächst einen
Mittelweg zwischen
drei Positionen finden müssen, die
im heutigen Diskurs sehr wichtig sind.
Was wir meiner Meinung nach vermeiden müssen,
wenn wir philosophisch über Digitalisierung sprechen wollen,
ist Ideologie,
also einige Leute, besonders diese  die
an der Silicon-Valley-Ideologie festhalten, wie
Julia, kein Gerücht hat es in
letzter Zeit genannt,
sie begreifen die Digitalisierung als eine
Art Erlösung, es ist ein Heilsversprechen,
auch in Bezug auf Transhumanismus und so weiter.
Ich denke, das ist der falsche Weg,
um dann philosophisch über Digitalisierung zu sprechen
Ich denke auch, dass der Reduktionismus, die
Digitalisierung als bloßes technisches Werkzeug,
eine Simulation war, äh, greift zu kurz,
und schließlich ist das, was ich als Diskriminierungsdigitalisierung
bezeichne, eine Gefahr für die Moderne, also
all diese Skeptiker der Digitalisierung. Ich
denke, das ist nicht
das Philosophischste, was wir
über
Digitalisierung sagen können  ist meine alternative
ich denke, dass alle drei positionen fa
kurz weil sie nicht
zwischen digitalisierung und digitalität unterscheiden
sie verfehlen auch die
lebensweltlich bedeutsame
bedeutung der digitalisierung als ein
phänomen eigener art begrifflich zu erfassen und ich finde das
besonders wichtig
es ist ein phänomen seiner eigenen art was
heißt das
ein phänomen  also die
digitalisierung ist ein technischer prozess
, der sich in verschiedenen bereichen der
gesellschaft, der
wirtschaft, der politik, der wissenschaft, der ausbildung
usw., der universität abspielt
und sie disruptiv verändert
von
äh Revolution ist es eine disruptive
Transformation
und das ist wirklich interessant, aber wir
können philosophisch noch weiter gehen,
denn Digitalität betrifft das Leben von
der Bedeutung dieser disruptiven
Transformationen
als Phänomene ihrer eigenen Art und
stellt
daher eine eigene Ontologie mit eigenen Gesetzen dar
und
was i'  Ich werde eine Art
beschreiben  Ich möchte diese eigene Ontologie
und ihre eigenen Gesetze,
die mein Ansatz zur Digitalisierung sind, auf
philosophische Weise skizzieren.
Daher ist Digitalität ein
antireduktionistischer Ansatz
für das Phänomen der Digitalisierung,
jenseits des bloßen Reduktionismus, jenseits der
Ideologie des Transhumanismus und jenseits
anderer konkurrierender Ansichten
zu diesem Phänomen, die ich zuvor skizziert habe
Kommen wir also zum nächsten Punkt, dem
Unterschied zwischen Simulation
und virtueller Realität. Ich denke, es ist
wirklich wichtig,
diesen Unterschied zu verstehen,
um dem Phänomen der Digitalität gerecht zu werden. Das von mir zitierte
Oxford-Handbuch der Virtualität
sagt, dass es derzeit eine
weit verbreitete ontologische Verwirrung über
virtuelle Realität gibt  die realität und ihre beziehung zur
realen welt,
was zu einem fehlerhaften
verständnis der virtuellen realität
und ihres potenzials beiträgt
ich denke, das ist eine wirklich interessante
diagnose, weil
es wirklich tiefe verwirrung gibt, also zuerst
gibt es die virtuelle realität und ihren strikten
sinn
und dann gibt es wir sind und sind
Wir sind virtuelle Realität  wie wir sind und
sie sind
Augmented Reality, also unterscheide ich
virtuelle Realität
von vr und ar. Ich denke, es ist nicht dasselbe
und es ist wirklich wichtig,
zwischen diesen
drei Phänomenen zu unterscheiden, also ist
vr eine ausgeklügelte Simulation der Realität
, die uns in verschiedenen Kontexten helfen kann
hilfreich eine technologisch
interessante Sache auch in Bezug auf
Computerspiele und so weiter, aber
es ist eine Simulation, am Ende ist es eine
Simulation,
und meiner Meinung nach können wir diese
Dinge danach diskutieren
ist meiner Meinung nach eine bloße
Simulation, eine sehr ausgeklügelte, aber
es ist keine Realität, es sollte im Grunde keine Realität sein,
also denke ich, dass es wichtig ist,
c3-
Konzepte zu unterscheiden, und jetzt komme ich
dazu, über das zu sprechen, was David Chalmers
kürzlich
als virtuellen Realismus und virtuell bezeichnet hat
Digitalismus,
so sagt er, ein virtueller Realismus besteht aus
den drei
diesen vier Sätzen ersten virtuellen
Objekten, die
wirklich existieren  2. Ereignisse in der virtuellen
Realität finden
wirklich statt 3. Erfahrungen in der
virtuellen Realität sind nicht illusorisch
4. virtuelle Erfahrungen sind genauso wertvoll wie nicht-virtuelle Erfahrungen, daher kann der vierte Punkt
als eine Art
normativer Satz angesehen werden
und er hat ihn auch geprägt  der begriff des
virtuellen digitalismus es gibt zwei
vorstellungen, die er gibt
erstens virtuelle objekte existieren wirklich und
sind digitale objekte zweitens ereignisse in
virtuellen welten sind größtenteils digitale
ereignisse
, die wirklich stattfinden ich finde das
interessant, weil
er im grunde
virtuelle
virtualität mit der realität verbindet  und ich denke, das ist
richtig,
aber ich stimme ihm in
seiner konzeption des virtuellen digitalismus nicht zu,
weil ich denke, dass es auch
virtuelle objekte gibt
, die keine digitalen objekte sind, die
nicht dasselbe sind,
dass es virtuelle objekte geben könnte, die keine
digitalen objekte sind,
und  Es gibt ein weiteres Zitat von
David Chalmers. Er sagt, die große
Mehrheit der Philosophen, die geschrieben
haben  Zehn über virtuelle Welten sind
virtuelle Luftakrobaten, genauer gesagt,
sie sind der Ansicht, dass virtuelle
Welten fiktive Welten sind. Man könnte diese
Sichtweise als
virtuellen Fiktionalismus bezeichnen. Zweitens ein weiteres
Zitat. Virtuelle Realität
ist eine Art allgemeine Realität. Virtuelle
Objekte sind reale Objekte,
und was in der virtuellen Realität vor sich geht, ist
wirklich real  also stimme ich zu, dass wir ihm vollkommen
zustimmen,
aber nicht in seiner These, dass Virtualität
notwendigerweise mit
digitalen Objekten verbunden ist, denn dies ist sein
neuer Artikel aus dem Jahr 2017, weil
das Oxford Handbook of Virtuality
dieses Zitat zu Recht betont,
trotz seiner jüngsten Verbindung
zur digitalen Domäne,
dem Virtuellen  hat eine lange Blutlinie
in Bezug
auf das Reale und das Tatsächliche und dass
Ideen und Anwendungen
der modernen digitalen Virtualität nur
Nachzügler auf der Party sind, also würde
ich sagen, dass die
Virtualität eine viel längere
Geschichte hat als
eine Digitalität oder eine digitale Virtualität,
also werde ich es tun  Nennen Sie einige Beispiele für eine
virtuelle
Realität, die über das digitale
Virtuelle hinausgeht  Realität zum Beispiel Schecks
Banknoten Währungen Unternehmen
Institutionen das sind alle in gewisser Weise
virtuelle Realitäten, weil sie nicht
materiell sind,
sie bestehen nicht nur aus
materiellen
Objekten, sondern sie sind abhängig von
Intersubjektivität
und Vereinbarungen und Regeln und so weiter, also
sind sie
äh virtuell  realitäten die nicht
digital sind
sicher gibt es einen riesigen bereich der virtuellen
digitalität
zum beispiel bitcoins virtuelle objekte in
computerspielen
online rollenspiele online prüfungen
twitter diskussionen
esports und nicht zuletzt zoom
konferenzen was ist gerade
so los  das sind alles phänomene
ereignisse oder
objekte wir können unterscheiden zwischen
ereignissen und objekten der
virtualität der digitalität und so weiter
also unterscheiden wir zwischen simulation
und virtueller realität
die beziehung zwischen digitalisierung
und digitalität entspricht der
beziehung zwischen
simulation und virtueller realität
virtualität muss gleichermaßen unterschieden werden
Simulation
und Fiktion  Obwohl es
etwas mit
diesen anderen Phänomenen wie Simulationsfiktion gemeinsam
hat, sind Simulationen nur Modelle, sie modellieren nur
Realitäten,
während virtuelle Realitäten eigenständige Realitäten sind
und ihre eigene Ontologie
haben. Unterscheiden wir also zwischen fiktiven
und illusorischen
Objekten, die fiktive Objekte nicht
brauchen  bezug auf ein reales modell sie sind in
gewisser weise unabhängig
das ist kreativität das ist die freiheit
des erfinders illusorische
objekte beziehen sich aber fälschlicherweise auf ein reales
modell also sind sie nicht
real und auch nicht fiktiv das ist eine
unterscheidung und dann können wir  Unterscheidung
zwischen Simulationen und virtuellen Objekten
Simulationen sind abhängig von ihrem realen
Lebensmodell
und haben keine unabhängige faktische Realität
und
Kausalität über ihren bloßen Zweck der
Simulation der
Realität hinaus virtuelle digitale Objekte
realisieren ihre Modelle auf andere Weise
sie sind nicht mehr abhängig von ihrer
Ontologie
wie Simulation oder  ihre Struktur, sondern
entfalten ihre eigenen autonomen Ursachen
sozusagen ein ontologisches
eigenleben, das seinen eigenen regeln gehorcht und damit
den bereich der digitalität betrifft, so wie ich es
verstehe,
so dass wir
jetzt zwischen realität,
virtualität,
simulation, fiktion und illusion unterscheiden können bzw. sollten, und ich
gebe einen
kurzen überblick  das ist nur ein
vorschlag wir können das
hinterher diskutieren ich denke es gibt
verschiedene realitäten
wo es eine physische realität gibt es eine
mentale realität wie
gedanken und emotionen
vielleicht zahlen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob wir noch eine
andere kategorie
wie zahlen haben sozusagen ideale objekte
und schließlich gibt es die
virtuelle Realität, das ist wie eine
Art Realität,
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir eine
Realität,
die aus Fiktionen, Simulationen
und Illusionen besteht, sodass wir klar erkennen können, dass
Virtualität nichts mit Simulation zu tun hat
, weil
Simulation eine Art von Realität ist  Realität,
während
Virtualität eine Art von Realität ist,
daher ist dies ein Vorschlag zur
Klärung
zwischen diesen Interessen  g aber unterschiedliche
konzepte lassen sie uns über die virtualität der digitalität sprechen,
also hier sind einige beispiele für digitale
virtuelle objekte
und dies ist der blaue partykopf
im online-straßenspiel
runescape, das
fast 1 700 us-
dollar wert ist. man sieht, dass der blaue kopf das
ist  ein eigenes Objekt, es ist in gewisser Weise eine
Simulation, es simuliert
einen echten blauen Kopf, aber es ist auch eine
Art Fiktion, weil
kein echter Kopf so aussieht, also gibt es
eine Kombination oder Verschmelzung
zwischen Fiktionssimulation
und Virtualität, im Grunde ist es ein virtuelles,
digitales, reales Objekt  und es hat
eine wirklich hohe Geburt, es ist wirklich
nicht sehr
billig, es ist teuer, also gibt
es andere
teurere Beispiele, z.
B. in Second Life
Es ist im
Grunde nicht nur ein Objekt, es ist eine
Struktur, es ist ein
Bereich, und schließlich können Sie hier
in diesem massiven Multiplayer-Online-Ego-
Shoot sehen  r entropia universe the crystal
palace and club never die ist
über 300 000 us-dollar wert jetzt sind dies nicht
nur simulationen
das sind reale einheiten, sondern virtuelle
einheiten, die man nicht berühren kann, aber man
kann mit ihnen interagieren
und sie haben eine eigene kausalität sie haben
eine inter  -subjektive
rolle spielen sie in unserer eigenen
welt eine virtuelle welt das sind drei
beispiele
die meiner meinung nach das äh
potenzial der virtuellen realität veranschaulichen
ähm jetzt möchte ich in seinem buch über das
internet
als ein was ich ein paradigma der digitalität nenne sprechen
über das internet
schreibt kuber dreifus meiner meinung nach zu recht er zitiert
das internet ist nicht nur eine neue
technologische innovation,
es ist eine neue art von technologischer
innovation, die das Wesen der technologie hervorbringt,
also transzendiert das internet die
technologie oder
begründet die technologie und  aus diesem
grund würde ich argumentieren, dass das internet
kein phänomen ist, weniger ein phänomen
der digitalisierung, sondern eher das, was ich
digitalität nenne
Es ist das Paradigma der Digitalität, wie
ich argumentieren werde,
also gibt es einige Gründe für meine Meinung.
Erstens ist das Internet
ein Medium zweiter Ordnung, was
bedeutet, dass es kein Medium ist,
nicht so sehr ein Medium, sondern die
Bedingung der Bedingung  Möglichkeit
der Medialität als solche er
begründet Medialität er macht Medialität
möglich
seine Infrastruktur, die es den
Menschen ermöglicht sofort unmittelbar zu
interagieren
usw. drittens ist er zu einem Grundbedürfnis geworden
wie Wasser Strom und Wärme er ist eine
Grundstruktur unseres Lebens er hat eine
lebenstiefe Bedeutung
a  wirklich wichtige bedeutung und
schließlich ist es ein freiheitskontext,
in dem virtuelle realität stattfindet
es ist das ähm es ist wirklich der
grund virtuelle realität macht es
möglich führen
wir drei kategorien von
digitalität ein digitalia sozusagen
wenn digitalität eine eigene sphäre bezeichnet
das  nicht ohne ontologischen Verlust auf die
nahe technische Seite der Digitalisierung reduziert werden
kann,
dann brauchen wir Kategorien o
Um es selbst zu verstehen, um es zu begreifen, und ich habe bereits
gesagt, dass es drei davon gibt, den allgegenwärtigen
Präsentismus, die
Transsubjektivität und schließlich die
Interobjektivität,
werde ich
diese drei
Kategorien der Digitalität so veranschaulichen, wie ich sie verstehe
erster ubiquitärer präsentismus raum und
zeit
spielen im bereich
digitaler virtueller realität eine andere rolle als in der
physischen welt wir sehen
am beispiel des internets, dass das
internet
die dinge in einer neuen ordnung zutiefst verbindet
digitale objekte
sind ortlos und soweit sie es sind  stehen
in horizontalen vernetzungsverhältnissen
wie im internet informationelle
vernetzung als informationelle beziehung
diese netzwerke sind nicht stabil, sondern
einem permanenten wandel unterworfen,
es handelt sich also nicht um eine stabile struktur, sondern um eine
wirklich sehr
dynamische dynamische struktur und schließlich entspricht
die zeit der digitalität
dem, was mctaggart genannt hat
die c-
Serie der Zeit, also gibt es eine neue Zeitordnung,
es sind nur Beziehungen,
es ist nicht später und b  Aber es ist
sozusagen eine logische Ordnung der Zeit,
und diese zusammen, ihre zeitliche Logik und
ihre
räumliche Logik,
die in der Vorstellung einer
allgegenwärtigen Präsentation zusammengeführt werden können, ist eine neue Art
von Raum und eine neue Art von Zeit, der wir
begegnen  in der digitalität besonders
im internet ist die nächste
kategorie das, was ich trendsubjektivität nenne wir können
transit subjektivität verstehen als eine
art externalisierung von gedanken
entsprechend ihrer logik von raum und zeit
in dieser allgegenwärtigen präsentation ist zum
beispiel
facebook eine art medium, das
subjektiv externalisiert  Zustände
wie Gefühle oder Meinungen
Gedanken so andere mentale Inhalte Ideen
Gedanken Meinungen Gefühle
können grundsätzlich von der
hypertextuellen Struktur
der Digitalität als Trägersubstanz
sozusagen aufgenommen
und von dem Individuum,
das sie produziert, gelöst werden,
damit wir unsere Gedanken so die Struktur teilen können
des Teilens
, das uns das Internet ermöglicht,
lässt sich mit dem Begriff
trans subje fassen  Aktivität diese Art der
Entsubjektivierung mentaler Inhalte
durch die Struktur der Teilung
Teilen Vernetzung
und Vermittlung ist das, was uns das Internet ermöglicht
und das ist
ein Phänomen der Digitalität
im Gegensatz zum rein technischen
Prozess
der Digitalisierung schließlich mein Begriff mein
Begriff von
Inter-  Objektivität, die ich vorschlagen möchte, dass
digitale Objekte in viel
engeren Beziehungen zueinander stehen als
physische Objekte, also haben wir gestern gehört, dass
das Internet der Dinge einen
Informationsaustausch
nicht nur zwischen Subjekten wie Personen,
sondern auch zwischen
Objekten, dem Internet der Dinge, gibt  sondern auch
zwischen
Personen und Objekten
Smart Objects sozusagen, also im
Internet der Dinge
kommunizieren Objekte, indem sie Informationen austauschen
und wir nehmen an dieser
Kommunikation teil und daher wird die Trennung
zwischen
Subjekten und Objekten zunehmend
aufgehoben, so dass zwischen diesen sozusagen eine Simulation stattfindet
Unterschied zwischen
Subjekten und Objekten
und das ist was  Ich nenne das
Interobjektivität und das
ist meiner Meinung nach eine wirklich entscheidende
Dimension der Sphäre der Digitalität im
Gegensatz
zu rein technischen Phänomenen
, die auf Digitalisierung reduziert
werden können. Vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit